he want me over you want me over when he
won money off of Kid Rock
I think he bet on Izzy oh did he really
there's an interaction between the two
of them after Izzy chaos him and it
looks like there's like a pocket a
handoff stimulus If he if he did if he
got that kid rock stimulus yeah dude if
he put money on Izzy 100 apparently the
people I knew that were at the fight
they're like when they showed Trump on
the screen nuts I heard the same thing
like there was the second loudest sound
of the night Behind The Knockout we'll
just talk about this in brilliant idiots
on brilliant idiots it's like this is in
Florida this is desantis's estate yeah
his literal State yeah and Trump is
going to wash him in Florida he's going
to watch him everywhere the guys it's
the primary not even gonna be close you
know what I also realize is is helpful
um the fact that for the last two years
we've had a president that is maybe
alive maybe not alive we're not exactly
sure like where where he is if somebody
came out now and they were like all
right Biden's been dead and we just
didn't want to tell people right we'd be
like okay we're not shocked right so we
know the country can run without a
president
Biden just said recently I'm saying this
one brilliant is that like he's like I
would love to do something about gun
control I just have no power to do it so
so he's basically saying the position is
powerless and it can run without
somebody who's coherent as president so
now that Americans kind of know it's
just like a fun position
put the fun guy here's if it was a smart
position like if it was like head of
mit's research lab for cancer we don't
want Trump yet right but if it's like
Dean of MIT yeah get Kid Rock in there
you don't want a fun guy because a fun
guy doesn't know that it's just for fun
and he's trying to do [__] yeah but but
he can't so it's like a baby you're like
okay here the plane is giving fake
nuclear codes 69 69 there it is he'll
believe it crazy
and he'll tell all the other leaders
like yo I got the new coach yeah triple
69. it's crazy how horny they are in the
Navy
it's a big thing that's what it is for
real he pokes out a little bit that's it
so I think I think I think he's a good
one I think
they've got to lock them up if they
don't then he wins and the fact that
they're trying to lock him up over some
absolute [__] compared to what other
politicians do yeah it is illegal but
it's not even close to as illegal as
like what Pelosi and her [__] husband
do with the stock market or what Hunter
and Joe Biden have done with the Ukraine
at the very least unethical
it's it is it is way less bad than the
steel dossier [__] yeah did we talk
about that like the clintons the DNC
paying for the steel dossier right so
it's like when you look at what they're
doing I understand why everybody who's
in the middle right like all the people
like I don't even like this [__]
but I hate these virtue signaling people
that are just complete Hypocrites so
because I despise them so much I'm a
ride for this dude
well you know what else I think Trump is
doing um additionally is he's not saying
anything about [__] going on here
outside of like the politicians he's not
he's not speaking on Race issues he's
not speaking on these things that always
make people be like God damn it dude now
I can't [__] I can't back it if he
continues doing that if he continues
doing that it's a [__] landslaughter
so I have the way that he wins
guaranteed I just don't know how he does
it wait
the way the winning strategy you you
feel you have it 100 what is it
he needs black women on his side I don't
know how he does it I don't know what he
can do to do it but if he can get black
women to be like nah we [__] with Trump
a subsidized Beyonce tour
I don't I it's like they don't they
don't even buy Beyonce's clothing
anymore like I think Beyonce might be
over relaxed I I I hate to say it but
it's like
Adidas let Beyonce take her clothing
back they were like let's just go they
didn't even let can you do that they're
like we still need to figure this out
but with with Beyonce they say keep your
[__] I spice running mate
that would work no nah no we'd actually
need to be serious about this
what can you do to win over black women
anybody running who has black women wins
he didn't have black women the first
time my G 2016.
remember when he won oh yeah
because of silk and diamonds you know I
just think if he can win over it it
doesn't have to be all black women but
if he can do something to win over black
women
it is a wrap
it is done because then he's completely
free white women can't complain about
him
white women can't say he's an [__]
can't say he's a racist can't say he's
hateful because black women shut the
[__] up you're all those things yeah so
black women can say to white women
you're all those things shut the [__] up
if Trump wins over half of the black
female vote you don't even need all of
them half also once black women [__]
with Trump every black dude is like oh
we free to [__] with him
against the gays the gays will pick it
up
to Macho Man he's gay he wears makeup
cares about his [__] no no Trump
don't bash the gays yeah I think that's
the group he needs he needs the black
case whoa because black women follow
everything to the Black Days
he's going to lose the Evangelical
Christians
but half of them are gay already he
needs he needs to yeah he needs yeah but
they don't want to come out they're
afraid to come out Mark how are you but
you vote in private I'm Saucy Santana we
need it publicly yeah we need we need
the public admission of support
how do we get that I I I've literally
been thinking about this since we did
brilliant idiots I'm like what would be
the thing that they could do what would
be the thing the Trump campaign could do
to convince black women that he has
their best interests at heart what do
black women care about more than
anything
I think they're children yeah I think
it's family
respect he doesn't check that box either
yeah he's not the most respectful
but how could he convince them that he
wanted the best for their children
yo what if he came out yeah he's gonna
have to lie
what if Trump came out and he was like
Inspirations
only black men want that [__] bro I'll
be honest with you I haven't heard a lot
of black women talk about reparations
and if it's helping everybody black it
will be awesome
in the white vote for sure what
reparations yeah then he loses landslide
that ain't gonna be it yeah but what
could he do to get black woman
what Akash bruh this is a [__] uphill
battle dawg they hated him for eight
years yeah we're just starting to find
him funny again and the second he starts
speaking on issues people are gonna be
like God damn it dude yeah he just got
to stay away from all who do they hate
besides him what do black women hate
white women
Tory Lanez Tory Lanez oh white what is
it white is it like white men
is it like pompous rich white men
no not really I think so no not really
they just they don't exist in their
world like they don't pay attention to
them yeah I would that's that makes
sense I think black dudes don't like
white dudes and white women don't like
white dudes hmm that's about it
I mean I don't mean to bring this
podcast to a screeching but I do think
it's an important issue
it's a tricky thing right yeah but if he
can even do it because it really frees
up black dudes because it seems like
every black dude I meet absolutely loves
Trump but they're terrified to admit it
stop it I I'll be honest you're speaking
on behalf of the two black dudes you
know
I know more black dudes than you stop it
this is not it's not just come on you
might be right but it doesn't help you
my haircuts get it to you bro bro you
don't even your business partner ain't
even black it's a fake black Jewish girl
really
that's not how Trump will win over the
place
her name is
from Morocco just just speak the truth
you're a Moroccan Jew 100
um
this is really good real black women
would have to lecture
sorry
I did it
um yeah we just got to pick who is the
culture curator for black women who are
the influencers for black women
but Beyonce don't talk Beyonce doesn't
have opinion she's not like a political
Rihanna will talk that [__] you know
it's like you could get Rihanna I think
you could yeah you could get Rihanna yo
yo yo who did Trump get out of
[__] Swedish oh [__] yep wait a
minute if he can get the gun charge in
Allegra
oh did he get that [__] drop now
and he comes out in Fenty if he wears
the Fenty Beauty and she's a billionaire
he's going to give her the tax breaks oh
my God we might be awesome
hold on this hat tight as [__]
shout out Waluigi but this house is
tight as [__] listen if we get Rihanna
which is very gettable she has two
children she cares more than anything
about those children he has to make sure
that they come up in a world that is
safe and supportive but keep going she
has another one coming in again oh yeah
it has not born yet but when he's
president count that yeah
we know that there you go you look at
Rihanna like there's still time
say that they're the first one
yo I think you to go after Rocky bro
yeah I think he got to go after Rocky I
think you got to clear that [__]
charge he's got to get Rihanna on board
yeah wow yeah I mean who else we have
Rihanna who else
black female influence Lauren London
I don't know if she has cultural
strongholds in black women really yeah
half Jewish too by the way
is she really there you go there you go
maybe infiltrating yeah
maybe make a nipsy hustle day or
something like that oh my God
during the New York City marathon day
just line those up the marathon
continues wow there it is there it is
that's good it's over wow it's a wrap I
got it son we giving them too many ideas
yes all I'm saying is I think it's very
possible for Trump and for whatever
reason I feel like the culture has
shifted a bit maybe because like you
said he hasn't really spoken on many
issues yeah as long as he's not speaking
on issues he can't be divisive and if
he's talking [__] about politicians
you're right we love it because they're
all pieces of [__] and sorry we look
weak as [__] right now internationally
and Trump being there
countries aren't going to talk the same
[__] because Trump will fire off oh I
know he's a wild boy loose candy yeah
it's um I also do think that like us not
looking good internationally is foreign
propaganda
ah I think the you know China I think
that maybe Saudi maybe Russia are doing
everything in their power to you know
put the gas on these stories that come
out about like here's this Union between
these different countries like the world
doesn't really want to use China as a
reserve currency like they can't trust
China it's like they have grand wizard
he might be one of the Ops bro oh [__]
he'd be pushing that propaganda you'd be
pushing down you're gonna break my
[__] heartbreak
this whole time every single podcast
I've gone I've been promoting the
greatest Instagram page of all time
Grand wizard chat word I can't say and
in reality you've been working for the
[__] Chinese this whole goddamn
saying they so bro yeah I'm just
tripping on granny that's the best
nickname to say that that's the best way
to say that Randy don't even sound
remotely offensive not at all yeah
it's my week at all our uh geopolitic
news
so funny when someone hits a group text
but damn you heard this world war three
and I've just been scrolling Instagram
and I know exactly where you got your
[__]
yeah why would they do that to what end
because I think division here is really
good yeah I think division is really
good and I actually think Trump will be
the most divisive candidate and they
actually want that because as long as
we're fighting amongst ourselves then
the the powers that be within this
country can't focus on you know Global
control
so they want us fighting amongst
ourselves as much as we possibly can
that's like that Pentagon leak the
Russian media was picking it up and they
were blasting it everywhere they're like
look at this league America is so
embarrassing and look at our numbers
we're killing it uh like they were
promoting that [__] on their channels
and I find it hard to believe that
that's the only thing that leaked from
the Pentagon there might be plenty of
things that leaked but they select the
ones that are going to get the views and
when you look at you know uh podcasts
you look at news sources what's trendy
right now what's trendy right now is the
de-dollarification of the world what's
trendy right now is U.S no longer the
global superpower what's trendy right
now is China is coming up and we've
fallen for that too so we're promoting
the things the propaganda if you will
that that is beneficial to the rest of
the world
so some of it might be truthful but to
really de-dollarify the world is like an
unbelievably difficult task here's my
one pushback that's probably not great
but Trump seems like the firmest hand
internationally I remember soccer saying
one thing he liked that Trump did is he
was very firm with China whereas most
politicians most U.S leaders have been
like yeah let China do their thing it's
fine we want to be friends with them and
China was and Trump was like [__] that
Trump seems like he's the most Stern
internationally like International
policy y'all are not gonna [__] with us
we're daddy so division here could be
worth that but is it for sure because
you're taking the chance on again like a
wild card maybe maybe
they don't want Trump maybe they want
Trump arrested and maybe it's worth
arresting Trump for some [__] just
to get him out of here yeah and maybe
they're the ones telling the Democrats
to put him behind bars Maybe